i know everyone's looking forward to new
music but i'm kind of
more obsessed with your chicken coop is
that your chicken
yeah that's my chicken coop i recommend
it if you have a little space
if you ever have you know want to take
on a project and
maybe you don't get as many as i got i
got 10 originally and that was way too
many
we were like you know we had so many
eggs we couldn't eat them all so
i gave a few away besides a little egg
farming during lockdown
sam's also been working on new songs and
says this new material
is a slight departure from his past
releases
i'm not writing directly from my life as
much on this record i'm experimenting
with
you know stepping outside of that more
honest place although there's gonna be a
lot of honesty in these songs and still
cut your music
now that my love life is a little more
steady um you know you have to draw from
scenarios that aren't necessarily
uh happening to you on a day-to-day
basis
do you run stuff by her and does she
give you like a yes or no or how does
that work i have to remind her that
you know don't read too much into these
lyrics
because even though i've had songs that
maybe were a little more honest not all
my songs are going to be
directly about my life and how i'm
feeling at that moment you know i may be
stepping in the shoes of a character
for a song so i have to be i have to be
careful
on certain songs to make sure she
doesn't read too much into
into the lyrics